We bring you again
Android next developer preview version
You can experiment with your application and discover new features.
Give feedback to our team
Hello everyone, I am Nasir Khan. I am the advocate of Android developers.
Android O has more control over the background's response
This is by increasing the use of RAM
Thereby improving interactive performance
Android Nougat prevents apps from receiving
Three special hidden broadcasts
Such as a new photo broadcast from an explicit receiver
Apps for O will no longer accept
Most implicit receivers of explicit receivers
Only a few exceptions are allowed
Such as BOOT_COMPLETED, LOCALE_CHANGED, etc.
Clear broadcast for application packages
Is registered in the description
Like ACTION_MY_PACKAGE_REPLACED.
When you start it, you register and
Received implicit broadcast
Background service for the application of Android O
Will only run for a short time, then there will be no
Visible activity or front screen service
Open the service, or the service is pending
Will throw an IllegalStateException
When the response is not in the background
Front screen services that require ongoing notifications
Kept working
There is a new API to start the front screen service directly
startServiceInForeground.
Finally, even if your response is not for O
There will be several changes
First, when your app enters the cache phase
That is to say, Android components that are not started
Any unlock will be sent automatically
Second, the location update will also change.
Apps that require background location updates
Just a few limited updates per hour
Front screen service is not affected
So, navigation or record movement
As they perform their location-dependent tasks
Can be updated very quickly
If another app is in front screen navigation
Then your background app can be used with the front screen app
Get the location update at the same frequency
We constantly improve the privacy of our users
So even if you don't target O
You will also notice changes in the Android ID in Settings.Secure
Inside O, it will return a different ID for different applications.
In other words, it now sets the scope of each application for each user.
This new feature will continue to be reinstalled when the app is reinstalled.
But for a simple, standard system to help the application profit
User reset
And replaced by the ID of the playback service provided by Google.
Also, considering privacy, applications for O
Cannot use the GET_ACCOUNTS license to get the user's account
Instead, the app must rely on account selection activities.
Account owner
Ability to choose whether the account is visible to other apps
Moreover, the account selection activity will be updated randomly.
Android O added a notification channel
Fine-grained control to give you more notifications
And let the app developer
More flexible delivery of different types of notifications
Rarely blocked
a notification channel
Is a notification that has been categorized from a single app.
Users can block a single category
Or change its actions, such as changing the button, increasing
Vibration and brightness, changing the privacy of the lock screen
You can use the channel to have different types of notifications
For example, a chat app will show two different conversations.
End users may apply different settings
a long button on the notification
[?带?] to channel settings
All applications that target O must implement the channel
Otherwise, the notice will not appear
It is easy to do
Just create a channel
Then call the channel in the notification creation
There are many features in user notifications
For example, the ability to notify during the time, set the timeout to cancel
The background color of the notification
Be sure to check for more details
Filling in the form is a time consuming
And error-prone tasks
New auto-filling framework makes application easier
Help their users do this
Android O allows users to choose auto-filled apps
Similar to how to choose a keyboard application
Autofill application is responsible for storing and protecting user data
, for example, address, credit card number
User name, even password, etc.
There is also a new visual API
You need to implement it in your custom vision
To guarantee metadata
Displayed in an auto-filled frame
The pictures in the picture are now available for all devices.
Not just for Android TV
And an application has to do just
Invoke input drawing in the back or stop drawing mode method
The system supports inputting pictures in the picture.
Like multiple video events
Entered the pattern of still pictures in the picture
If you have a social app, be sure to make sure
The playback can continue in the stopped state.
SetPictureinPictureArgs allows activities
Specify the size of the image within the image, scale
And remote custom action
This action allows the user to interact directly in the image activity within the image
Instead of making the app explicitly use the API demo
Regular events can now be launched on secondary displays
These impressions have basic settings in units of impressions
And resource management
This means some parts of this setup
Such as the width of the screen DP, height DP, and density DP
Will show according to the current activity
Fonts are now a fully supported resource type in Android
You can use the method of getting the font and get the font by its ID.
You can also qualify the entire font family in XML.
Choose font style and size
Resources based on fonts
There are more in the developer preview
Please check the preview page
Meet more about O and preview projects
View Android's developer channel
To watch more of these videos
Thank you everyone
(music)